[Music]
the UN kicked off its annual Global
gathering with a tribute to its host
planet Earth
and a nod to the many issues threatening
its inhabitants
we meet at the moment of great Peril for
our worlds conflicts and climate
catastrophe
mistrust and Division
poverty inequality and discrimination
dramatic visuals meant to inspire action
to protect the environment and dramatic
words first from American poet Amanda
Gorman I only ask that you care before
it's too late that you live aware and
awake that you lead with love in hours
of hate I challenge you to heed this
call I dare you to shape Our Fate next
from Global pop sensation black pink we
can't deny that the climate crisis is
getting worse there isn't a single
moment to lose Nobel Laureate Malala
yusufsai focused on education which has
seen setbacks globally thanks to covid
and conflict
in countries
like Ethiopia Ukraine and other
countries
are keeping Gus
out of the classroom
if you are serious
about creating a safe and sustainable
future for the children
then be serious about education
Samaya faruki was once the captain of
the Afghan girls robotics team now girls
like her are forbidden from attending
school
the Taliban is slowly erasing our
existence in the society
thousands of girls may never return back
to school
many have already been married of
climate covid and conflict all three
continue to weigh on the un's workload
with poor countries suffering the most
but in the words of the
secretary-general geopolitical divides
are putting us all at risk
singing sensation Angelique kidjo ended
the event on an upbeat note come Tuesday
it will be the most powerful countries
in the world in the crosshairs Kristen
salumi Al Jazeera the United Nations